yeah I learned the hard way too that
girls like when a guy has a plan ready
for the day he's got something planned
out which how did guys get stuck with
that chore
right I had a girl ask me out once we
show up we meet
she's like hey what are we doing I'm
like I don't know what are we doing
she's like you didn't play anything I'm
like no did you she's like no I'm like
well then you're just as worthless as me
why do I have to figure it out I believe
in equal rights can we work on this
together and she was like well it's very
manly when a guy plans a date no it's
not just convenient for you
how's that manly chopping wood is manly
wrestling a bear is mainly something
mainly about Googling topless and
bistros
come on ladies you got the right to vote
in 1920 let's use that on restaurants
huh I don't know where to go because I
have a dick I'm Zagat help me out what
the hell
manly come on I've noticed women only
call things manly when they like it
about a guy oh he pays for dinner he
protects me and stuff like oh he wants
to bang my friends going baldy so manly
ah